(pensive music)
(text buzzing)
- [Narrator] May 1st, 2003.
The US declares war
victory in Afghanistan.
- The bulk of this country today
is permissive, it's secure.
- [Narrator] The Taliban
had been toppled only months
after 9/11, and there were
some 13,000 NATO troops
in the country.
Fast forward nearly 20 years.
American soldiers have left,
the Taliban have come back,
and the United Nations
says civilian deaths
of women and children in Afghanistan
have hit record levels.
While it's difficult to map exactly
how much territory the
group actually controls,
limited data suggests it's
more than half of the country
with the insurgents claiming authority
over major border crossings
and infrastructure.
- Many people, both inside
and outside the country
have been surprised by the speed
and the scale of the Taliban's advances,
and by how fragile
the Afghan government's
authority is looking.
- It's time to end America's longest war.
It's time for American
troops to come home.
- [Narrator] Before Biden ordered
America's troops to leave,
the US had been trying
to exit for a while.
- And by the end of next year,
our war in Afghanistan will be over.
- [Narrator] But Taliban victories meant
that US soldiers remained
in the country much longer than intended.
- [Sune] And now the
foreign troops have gone
and the Taliban is steadily
taking over larger parts
of the country.
- [Narrator] Here's
how the insurgent group
has expanded to become stronger
than it's been in 20 years,
creating the conditions
for potential chaos
as US troops leave behind a country
on the brink of civil war.
At the beginning of the war,
America's campaign in Afghanistan
reached some milestones
in just a few months.
- When the US-led coalition
invaded Afghanistan,
the Taliban had controlled
the country for five years
after taking power following
an extremely violent civil war.
They'd imposed strick
Islamic rule on Afghanistan.
All that changed after 9/11
when President Bush set out
to punish the group for
harboring Al-Qaeda terrorists.
- The United States
military has begun strikes
against Al-Qaeda terrorist training camps
and military installations
of the Taliban regime in Afghanistan.
- [Narrator] Bush deployed
some 2,500 US troops
into the country,
causing the Taliban to abandon Kabul,
and soon thereafter Kandahar,
their main stronghold.
- The Taliban were a
broken force at that time.
They gave up barely without a fight
and melted back into society,
and retreated into villages.
Some Taliban commanders actually offered
to surrender in return for amnesty
but the US declined that offer
and wanted to keep fighting them.
They wanted to stamp out
every last terrorist from Afghanistan.
Instead, the Taliban regrouped in Pakistan
where they received shelter and support
with the aim of returning later.
- [Narrator] The Taliban
began their resurgence
and by the middle of the decade,
they had launched hundreds
of suicide attacks and
thousands of bombings,
killing hundreds of US soldiers.
(helicopter whirring)
So to counter their renewed presence,
Obama began deploying
more forces in the region.
- The United States has
conducted an operation
that killed Osama bin Laden,
the leader of Al-Qaeda.
- [Narrator] May 1st, 2011,
Osama bin Laden, the man held responsible
for the 9/11 attacks was killed
and around that period,
the number of US troops
in Afghanistan hit a peak
of around 100,000.
(gun firing)
But policymakers and experts began
to question the effectiveness
of that large military presence.
- What became clear
was that the US counterinsurgency strategy
did not eradicate the Taliban.
In fact, some of the more
controversial tactics
that the US used in Afghanistan,
such as night raids and
arbitrary detentions,
and air strikes that
sometimes killed civilians
created this contempt
in local communities,
and actually helped the
Taliban recruit more fighters.
- [Narrator] The Taliban's
recruitment drive enabled them
to increase in numbers
and gain control of yet more territory,
launching near daily attacks
against the US and Afghan forces.
So with bin Laden dead and
facing mounting pressure
from Democratic lawmakers in Congress,
Obama announced his plan to
withdraw some 33,000 troops
from the region and transfer power
to the Afghan military.
- Our mission will change
from combat to support.
By 2014, this process of
transition will be complete,
and the Afghan people will be responsible
for their own security.
- That plan didn't work as intended.
The Afghan security forces were plagued
by problems that continued to haunt them,
such as corruption, which made them
an ineffective fighting
force against the Taliban
who continued to fight,
allegedly armed and funded by Pakistan.
- [Narrator] The Afghan government
has acknowledged problems
with effectiveness and corruption
among its security forces
but told The Journal that
corruption is decreasing.
And Pakistan's government has
denied backing the Taliban
but says it has some limited
influence over the group.
This map shows just how much territory
the Taliban had taken over in 2017.
- [Sune] The Taliban's gradual advances
across the country really
began alarming people
in the capital.
- [Narrator] After NATO announced the end
of its combat mission,
(lively music)
the Taliban scored symbolic victory,
such as capturing the city of Kunduz.
(guns firing)
While mapping the
Taliban's exactly presence
has been tricky in such a fluid situation,
some analysts have drawn maps based
on news reports and social media
that outline the group's
territorial control from 2017.
At the time, the Afghan military
was already struggling
to hold the Taliban back,
and Trump announced he
was sending more troops.
- The security threats
we face in Afghanistan,
and the broader region are immense.
- President Trump's
announcement fueled the will
to fight among some fighters.
I remember speaking to
young Taliban fighters
who said that they'd actually
considered giving up the war
once the American troops left.
But once President Trump said
he was gonna send more troops,
they said there was no way
they were gonna give up the fight.
- [Narrator] Around four years
later, on July 4th, 2021,
US troops finally left Bagram,
their main base of
operations in the country.
Meanwhile, the Taliban's
expansion accelerated.
- We cannot continue
this cycle of extending
or expanding our military
presence in Afghanistan.
- [Narrator] As foreign troops pulled out,
insurgents took many districts
without having to fight.
The group has been trying
to show a friendlier face,
posting propaganda videos purporting
to show Taliban fighters shaking hands
with Afghan soldiers
or guarding borders
without disrupting trade.
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] The Afghan
government didn't respond
to a request for comment on these images.
Analysts say it's part of a campaign
to legitimize the insurgency
amid negotiations with
the Afghan government.
While the Biden administration
says America's military campaign
has accomplished its objectives,
US air strikes against the Taliban
are expected to continue.
And America plans to keep
monitoring terrorist threats.
People in Afghanistan question
what the Taliban's plans are,
and whether they can coexist
with the Afghan government.
- The Taliban's gains raise
two main risks for Afghanistan.
One, that the country might split possibly
along sectarian lines,
which could throw the country
into another bloody civil war,
or that a fundamentalist
Islamist group takes power
in Afghanistan again,
which would undermine the
whole purpose of the war,
which was to eradicate terrorism
risks from the country.
(dramatic music)